we have got a great story but we're
missing the first paragraph in this
story it says that that bit got torn off
so you've got a great story from then on
but you don't know what happened right
at the beginning the first page um well
then our our first question really is do
we have to have a beginning I mean it's
nice to have one all stories start with
once upon a time um and do we need one
do we need a first cause or are some
scientists happy that we don't have one
and it is our preference for having a
beginning because you lot have inherited
that that sort of myth structure from
from Christianity I mean I don't think
the engines are too worried about this
yes Oh Jeff do you think we we have to
have a beginning or is it just a an
article of faith well currently my
scheme does not have a beginning but the
beginning that we think of as the Big
Bang was the continuation of something
which didn't look like a Big Bang but it
was an previously expanding what I call
an eon and these went on as far as the
theory goes indefinitely so there was no
beginning in this scheme of course that
might not be right but I think there are
some observations very recent
observations which I don't see how you
can explain on the basis of current
inflationary theory and I rather
disagree about inflation being a nice
beautiful theory it's a very artificial
theory where you have to introduce
concepts which just before we get on to
that when you say an eon have I got the
right picture that basically they're
saying before our universe our current
what it was for it yes and it sort of
came to an end and then there's another
one it's an old idea that the universe
expanded and then collapsed again so
we're dispensing with beginnings and
endings let me just go back to the old
idea see this was one of the very old
originally right after Einstein produced
his theory Friedman solved the equations
and one of the solutions was a universe
which expanded and collapsed like this
and it went through these phases no this
is very different because it never
collapses and that's what people have
trouble swallowing you see how can this
universe which is expanding getting
rarefied cold and all that become this
Big Bang which is very hot and
compressed and they look completely
different but they're not completely
different if you don't have mass because
it's a funny idea but in this model when
you don't have clocks around which you
don't when you don't have mass then big
and small become equivalent it's what
you call conformal equivalent large
things and small things you can't tell
them apart if you don't have a scale
which tells the difference and the scale
gets lost when you don't have particles
with mass and so when that scale is lost
this expanding indefinitely expanding
universe becomes a big bang of the next
even though it was very large what spawn
yes okay when you see lose track of what
large means when you've only got photons
running around there's no meaning to
saying it's large or small the equations
become identical I agree it's a hard
idea to swallow and it's Thank You Roger
would you rather you want to say
something in terms of your question can
we do with the universe that isn't ever
beginning certainly we can but we
observe that that's not the case with
our universe we know our universe at the
beginning so we don't get to have a
choice on that and in terms of the
theory of cosmic inflation explaining
many of the features we observe in our
universe I I did state before that it's
a beautiful and natural theory that's
true except that it has a very very
unnatural feature which is the one that
Roger pointed out in the 70s I believe
that the chance of starting a universe
with high energy inflation is incredibly
small
it's 1/2 the power and and in that sense
yes I completely agree with Roger that
that's a very unnatural beginning to
have a very special
beginning to have but that argument is a
consequence of the second law of
thermodynamics we can turn it around and
say our universe study started at an
incredibly small entropy or at an
exquisitely ordered state at a very
special state so always give the problem
of the origin of the universe whether
it's via cosmic inflation or via some
other mechanism or some other theory
that problem will always be tied up with
the issue of the second law of
thermodynamics by which entropy always
gross so whatever beginning we can
conceive of in the future the entropy of
that state of that ground so that
beginning would will always be special
relative to some final state and and
that is the part where I'm not sure I
agree with Roger any further I I like
his his theory of eons and cycles in the
universe but I have not thought
carefully on how that evades the second
law of thermodynamics
you